[Music]  the frameworks in this course will be  helpful to anyone in a digital health  company whose work touches the product  or the customer and the insights can  help health system leaders evaluate and  implement digital solutions  so wherever you sit in the digital  health ecosystem  this course will help you navigate the  needs of key stakeholders like patients  doctors payers and innovators  and how to leverage digital tools to  create value for them and you'll  understand how the culture and  real-world practice of medicine  makes digital transformation and health  care entirely different  from transformation of any other field